GILLIAN:  PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOW
ARRIVING IN NORFOLK, VIRGINIA.
WE DON’T HAVE THOSE LIVE
PICTURES TO BRING TO YOU JUST
YET BUT WE WILL MOMENTARILY, AS
SOON AS WE DO.
IN THE MEANTIME, LET’S BRING
BACK OUR MEDICAL PANEL OF
EXPERTS, THEY ARE GOING TO
ANSWER SOME MORE OF YOUR
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
SUBMITING TO US ALL MORNING
LONG.
AGAIN, LET’S WELCOME FOX NEWS
MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR,
DR. JEANETTE NESHEIWAT AND
MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF INFECTIOUS
DISEASE PREVENTION AT ASCENSION,
DR. MAGGIE HAGEN.
THE FIRST QUESTION COMES FROM
VIEWER CHRISTOPHER DIAZ WHO SAYS
WITH TESTING I KNOW WE CAN’T
TEST EVERYONE WITH NO SYMPTOMS
FOR THE VIRUS BUT WILL IT BE
POSSIBLE TO TEST EVERYONE FOR
THE ANTIBODIES SO THOSE PEOPLE
CAN GO BACK TO WORK?
>> THAT’S A GOOD QUESTION.
WE BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
INFECTED WITH COVID-19 WILL
DEVELOP AN ANTIBODY TO THE VIRUS
THAT WILL BE PROTECTIVE.
HOW LONG THAT PROTECTION WILL
LAST, WHETHER IT WILL BE A FEW
MONTHS OR A FEW YEARS, WE DON’T
KNOW.
BUT THE ABILITY TO MEASURE THAT
ANTIBODY WOULD CERTAINLY BE
HELPFUL TO KNOW WHO HAS BEEN
INFECTED.
AS YOU KNOW, MANY OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE INFECTED DON’T HAVE
SYMPTOMS THAT BRING THEM TO
MEDICAL ATTENTION.
SO IF WE HAVE THAT ANTIBODY
TEST, THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
THERE ARE SOME VERY PRELIMINARY
DATA LOOKING AT ANTIBODIES AND
AS YOU MAY BE AWARE, EVEN
STUDIES LOOKING AT USING
ANTIBODIES FROM PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN INFECTED AS TREATMENT FOR
THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY BATTLING
THE DISEASE.
SO A LOT OF WORK IS BEING DONE
REGARDING ANTIBODIES AND WE
WOULD BE HOPEFUL IN THE FUTURE
THAT THAT TESTING WOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE.
GILLIAN:  DR. NESHEIWAT, WE HAVE
A QUESTION FROM VIEWER RAY
SANDERS WHO SAYS IF YOU HAPPEN
TO GET COVID-19, WOULD USING A
NEBULIZER HELP YOUR ISSUE WITH
YOUR LUNGS OR WILL IT MAKE THE
SITUATION WORSE?
>> SO MY PATIENTS FOR EXAMPLE
WHO HAVE ASTHMA AND WHO TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID, THEY HAVE
EXPRESSED TO ME AND I HAVE SEEN
IMPROVEMENT IN THEIR OXYGEN
LEVEL AND O2 STATS WITH
ALBUTEROL INHALERS AND NEBULIZER
TREATMENT.
THE PROBLEM IS, WHEN YOU USE A
NEBULIZER MACHINE, YOU COULD BE
AIRING THE VIRUS AND IT COULD
SPREAD IN THE ROOM AND YOU COULD
POTENTIALLY MAKE OTHER PEOPLE
ILL.
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL AND KEEP
THAT IN MIND.
IF YOU’RE GOING TO USE A
NEBULIZER MACHINE, TO HELP WITH
YOUR BREATHING, TO HELP WITH
YOUR ASTHMA, TO TREAT THE
SHORTNESS OF BREATH THAT WE
COMMONLY SEE, YOU WANT TO USE IT
IN ONE ROOM OF THE HOUSE WHERE
YOU ARE SO WE DON’T SPREAD VIRAL
PARTICLES TO OTHER PEOPLE
BECAUSE THAT IS A CONCERN.
GILLIAN:  WE ARE TAKING A LIVE
LOOK THERE FOR OUR VIEWERS AT
HOME AT AIR FORCE ONE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS JUST LANDED IN
NORFOLK, VIRGINIA.
HE’S ABOUT TO DEPLANE.
WE’LL KEEP AN EYE ON THAT FOR
YOU.
IN THE MEANTIME, DR. HAGEN, I’M
GOING TO COME BACK TO YOU.
WE’VE GOT A QUESTION FROM DANA
GILBERT WHO SAYS IS IT TRUE YOU
SHOULD AVOID IBUPROFEN, ALLEVE
AROUND ASPIRIN IF YOU GET
COVID-19.
I KEEP HEARING ABOUT THAT.
>> THERE’S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT IBUPROFEN OVER
THE PAST COUPLE WEEKS.
THERE WERE CONCERNS THAT IT
PERHAPS COULD MAKE THE VIRAL
INFECTION WORSE AND IN FACT SOME
COUNTRIES EVEN CAME OUT WITH A
WARNING AGAIN AGAINST USING THAT
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
CAME OUT WITH A STATEMENT ON THE
17th OF THE MONTH SAYING THEY
WERE LOOKING INTO THE ISSUES
REGARDING IBUPROFEN.
THE VERY NEXT DAY THEY CAME OUT
WITH A STATEMENT SAYING THEY
DIDN’T HAVE ANY DATA THAT
SUGGESTED YOU SHOULD NOT USE
IBUPROFEN.
THAT BEING SAID, TO TREAT THE
SYMPTOMS OF FEVER, THE BODY
ACHES, YOU MIGHT CONSIDER USING
ACETAMINOPHEN.
WE BELIEVE THAT IS SAFE FOR
TREATING THE SYMPTOMS OF COVID.
GILLIAN:  SO MAYBE
ACETAMINOPHEN.
DR. NESHEIWAT, WANT TO THROW THE
NEXT QUESTION TO YOU.
THIS COMES FROM VIEWER NAMED
NADINE.
SHE SAID I AM HAVING A BABY IN
JULY AND I’M GETTING NERVOUS.
I’M WORRIED ABOUT BRINGING A
BABY INTO ALL OF THIS.
QUICK NOTE, SOUNDS LIKE THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION SAYS
THEY DON’T KNOW A LOT ABOUT IN
UTERO TRANSMISSION.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT IT?
>> SURE.
SO WE SAW NINE CASES -- I READ
ABOUT NINE CASES IN CHINA WITH
NINE MOMS WHO GAVE BIRTH AND
THERE WAS NO FETAL MATERNAL
TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS TO THE
NEWBORN BABY.
THERE WAS ONE CASE WHERE A 30
HOUR OLD BABY TESTED POSITIVE
FOR CORONAVIRUS BUT DID VERY
WELL AND RECOVERED VERY QUICKLY
AND HAD NO COMPLICATIONS.
BUT FIRST OF ALL,
CONGRATULATIONS ON HAVING A
BABY.
THE BEST WAY TO PROTECT YOURSELF
AND TO PROTECT YOUR BABY IS TO
PROTECT YOURSELF, FOLLOW THE CDC
GUIDELINES OF HAND WASHING,
SOCIAL DISTANCING, STAYING
HYDRATED, TAKING PRENATAL
VITAMINS.
YOU’LL BE GIVING BIRTH IN JULY,
IN THE SUMMER.
HOPEFULLY THE HEAT WILL DIMINISH
THE AMOUNT OF CASES AND YOU
WON’T HAVE TO WORRY AS MUCH.
GILLIAN:  DEFINITELY A QUESTION
IN MY FRIEND GROUP WITH SO MANY
PEOPLE EXPECTING AND NEW MOMS, A
LOT OF WOMEN ARE ASKING WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN FOR US.
NOT A LOT OF INFORMATION OUT
THERE, SADLY.
BUT THANKS FOR BRINGING US WHAT
WE DO KNOW AT THIS MOMENT.
DR. HAGEN AND DR. NESHEIWAT,